- Même tôt dans la matinée,
ce poste frontalier est bienmamn
est surtout dense dans
une direction.
Depuis l'annonce
d'une mobilisation partielle
en Russie, on a constaté
une augmentationfréquentation àe
situé entre Saint-Pétersbourg
et Helsinki.
pas question de participer
à cette guerre, surto
qu'il est à la fois Russe
et Ukrainien.
fermés et des billets dont
les prix ont explosé, la voiture
ou l'autobus sont devenues
des options privilégiées.
un aller simple.unununununununun
générale, ce moscovite devra
envisager une nouvelle vie,
hors de son pays.
À la frontière, l'activité est
continue, mais n'a rien à voiren
ou en Géorgie. Pour entrer
en Finlande et donc dans l'Union
européenne, les conditions sont
avoir un visa imprimé
dansonon passeport.
Helsinki a annoncé
son intention de resl'l'l'l'l'le
aux ressortissants russes
munis d'un visa de touriste.
Il faut dire que le gouvernement
à d'importantes pressions
venant d'autres pays européens,
mais aussi de ses propres
citoye
- Slava Ukraini!
- Chaque mardi, au coeur
d'Helsinki, Finlandais
à une manifestation contre
la guerre menée par la Russie.ot
des Russes qui fuient leur pays
ne s'opposent pas nécessairement
à la guerre, mais plutôt à
"Ça ne les dérangeait pas
quand d'autres personnes
tuaient des Ukrainiens,
ils ont été silencieux.
Aujourd'hui,lsls ont peur
pour leur vie."
Plus qu'une interdictiontetetee
demande aux autorités
finlandaises de fermer
la frontière.fefefefefefefefefe.
- Elle assure ne pas se sentir
en sécurité avec la présence
croissante de ressortissants
d'adoption.
aiais pour certains, bloquer
tous les passages frontaliers
n'est pas une
qui ne veulent pas participer
à d c crimes de guerre",
dit ce député de gauche.
S'il appuie les restrx x x x xe
touriste, l'élu estime qu'il
faut continuer d'accueillir
les demandeurs d'asile.
Ailleurs sur le continent,
l'enjeu divise les différentsqus
semaines, des pays alliés
avaient déjà grandement limité
l'accès à leur territoire.
1300 kilomètres de frontière
avec la Russien'n'avait plus
le choix de suivre le pas.
IRO SÄRKKÄ, politologuersrsrsrsi
- La Finlande était devenue,
pendant les mois de l'été,
une zone de transit des Russes
en Europe.
que le gouvernement finlandais
maintenant ne peut pas accepter,
parce
nos relation internationales
et européennes.
à entrer en Finlande avant
que la nouvelle potitique
soit appliquée.
Difficile pour ce jeune hommel.
Premier arrêt à Helsinki;
pour le reste, il ne sait
toujours pas quelles routes
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair,
Radio-Canada, Helsink